des astronautes qui mangent dans
l'espace ça n'a rien de nouveau au fil
des décennies ils ont essayé le Chili la
pizza les sushis mais ce qu'il ne faut
pas oublier c'est qu'il y a un service
de livraison la station spatiale est à
400 km au-dessus de tête on peut la
ravitailler mais quand on parle de base
sur la lune c'est 1000 fois plus loin et
sur Mars un million de fois bref
impossible de faire livrer de la
nourriture il faut qu'au moins une
partie soit produite sur place
la NASA et l'Agence spatiale canadienne
organisé un concours pour stimuler des
idées plusieurs équipes au pays ont
répondu présent on a choisi d'en visiter
trois et on en a profité pour récolter
des algues et des grillons question de
voir ce qui pourrait au menu sur Mars
avec le chef cuisinier Dany St-Pierre ok
il va falloir faire preuve de créativité
faire pousser de la nourriture sur la
lune ou sur Mars c'est loin d'être
évident mais avec le climat qu'on a au
Canada on est bien placé pour trouver
des solutions
de travail sur le défi de l'alimentation
dans l'espace lointain on est impatient
de montrer au jus ce qu'on a fait
pousser
c'est un grand jour pour moi je suis
très fier
voilà les juges
j'ai le privilège de vous dévoiler notre
chambre de croissance Canada Goose vous
devriez pouvoir sentir le basilic
l'équipe de l'Université de guelf ne
fait pas seulement pousser du basilic il
y a trois niveaux de plateau mais aussi
des radis des salades des tomates des
haricots du Cail des plantes choisis
notamment pour leur croissance rapide
[Musique]
quand on conçoit un système en vue de
l'envoyer dans l'espace il y a beaucoup
de contraintes à respecter au premier
coup d'oeil on voit bien que le
prototype est beaucoup trop lourd c'est
qu'en fait le système développé pour le
concours c'est la partie à l'intérieur
qu'on a mis dans une chambre de
croissance déjà existante parce que les
recherches ici n'ont pas commencé avec
le lancement du concours
a commencé en 1995
et les étudiants diplômés que vous avez
rencontrés sont au sommet de leur art
pour relever ce défi
sa carrière et une des plus grandes
avancées technologiques ce sont les
éclairages d'elle ils ont remplacé les
vieilles ampoules qui consommaient
beaucoup d'énergie et surtout il
permettent de contrôler la croissance
des végétaux lucen change on peut
changer la taille la forme la couleur le
goût toutes sortes de caractéristiques
physiologiques des plantes juste en
jouant avec le spectre de la lumière
avec sa couleur
l'autre chose dont les plantes ont
besoin c'est du CO2 la bonne nouvelle
c'est que les astronautes comme tous les
humains en expire les plantes le
transforment en oxygène elle purifie
l'air pour une éventuelle base sur la
lune ou sur Mars my Dixon estime que
pour nourrir chaque astronaute il faut
50 mètres carrés c'est à peine le quart
de terrain de tennis ces recherches ont
aussi des débouchés sur terre
la recherche sur les systèmes de
maintien de la vie peut déboucher sur
des transferts technologiques au secteur
agroalimentaire pour des siècles à venir
même si on ne va jamais sur Mars les
retombées technologiques et économiques
sont très nombreuses pour le Canada
pour les astronautes il ne faut pas
négliger un aspect celui du plaisir de
jardiner et de récolter
plus grands avantages d'une chambre de
croissance c'est qu'on produit des
aliments qu'on est déjà habitué de
manger quand ça pousse dans l'espace ça
ne droponie t'as quand même un légume
qui est frais qui est de qualité que
jamais vu un frigo que tu cueilles à
mesure que des gains
tu veux manger tu vas être diverti et on
a accès aux légumes mais ça va quand
même prendre des protéines mais ça dans
les gonzes astronautes c'est on les vu
fort vigoureux et vif on les légumes
c'est le fun mais ça prend d'autres
choses
[Musique]
c'est clairement autre chose qu'une
équipe de l'université miggyl a fabriqué
leur objectif c'est de cultiver les
micro-algues ce qui n'était pas le
premier choix d'Ilias adhère moi je suis
pas d'accord je voulais pas faire de
micro-alpes à la fin ils m'ont convaincu
on a fait une recherche préliminaire on
a vu bon qui avait des systèmes qui
existaient par-ci par là on s'est dit on
va partir sans idée préconçue on va tout
construire de zéro
ce qui pousse c'est de la spiruline en
suspension dans l'eau
leur prototype est hypnotisant mais ce
n'est pas là-dessus qu'il compte pour
séduire le jury de l'Agence spatiale
canadienne mais sur l'automatisation
[Musique]
il suffit d'ajouter des nutriments dans
l'eau et de remuer
l'équipe cherche avant tout à maximiser
la production pour nourrir les
astronautes
on doit vraiment contrôler des variables
environnementales on parle du pH on
parle du CO2 on parle du de qui est
dissout on parle de la température etc à
terme il y aura six réservoirs autour
d'un cœur où se trouve l'éclairage ici
aussi les lampes d'ailes réduisent la
consommation d'énergie
lors de la visite du jury c'était le
jour 1 d'un nouveau cycle de production
[Musique]
deux semaines plus tard l'équipe en a
récolté pour nous de façon un peu
artisanale
la couleur est vraiment belle
[Musique]
on peut littéralement faire des gnocchis
à partir de ça à mon coup de cœur moi
c'est le gnocchis
[Musique]
de la saveur aux algues et Dany
Saint-Pierre avait vraiment hâte
d'expérimenter avec leur échantillon
je sais pas si on va prendre une
assiette blanche ok ça c'est vraiment
excitant
garde le vert qui était capable d'aller
sortir tu vois comme je faisais rentrer
de m'amuser avec ça
c'est pas de la quantité que j'ai aimé
quelque chose
[Musique]
pour la dernière équipe qu'on a choisi
on a assisté à tout un branle-bas de
combat tellement qu'on a eu l'impression
qu'ils ont construit leur prototype sous
nos yeux comme vous voyez du monde qui
se promène partout écoutez il reste une
heure arrive bientôt on se prépare le
plus qu'on peut on a fait le ménage je
pense que ça devrait assez bien aller
l'équipe d'Alexander Baker et de Cynthia
Haïti amisé sur les protéines animales
évidemment pas question d'élever des
poulets sur la lune mais élevez des
grillons ce n'est pas nécessairement
plus simple à chaque fois on pensait on
va faire comme ça comme ça on va faire
ça comme ça
quand il y a pas de dors
plus de contraintes le plus qu'on
avançait on réalisait vraiment que ça
soit très bien planifié notre affaire
leur prototype c'est une série de
tiroirs dans le premier des grillons
adultes vont fournir des centaines d'eux
par semaine
les grillons mangent à peu près
n'importe quoi dans un contexte de base
lunaire ou martienne ça pourrait être
des restes de table ou de culture de
légumes par exemple après 6 semaines de
croissance les grillons sont prêts à
être récoltés
[Musique]
faire sécher les grillons puis les
broyer pour obtenir une farine riche en
protéines
[Musique]
l'équipe pense être sur la bonne voie
pour élever des grillons sur la lune ou
sur Mars on est très fier d'avoir créé
un prototype qui est capable de
contrôler cette espèce chaotique et
vraiment notre but c'était vraiment de
séparer l'humain l'astronaute
l'utilisateur du système du grillon pour
qu'on aille toucher pour pas que ça soit
je veux pas toucher avec des insectes
pour certains des grillons ce n'est pas
très appétissant mais c'est déjà utilisé
en cuisine
ça se renouvelle c'est une protéine qui
se renouvelle très très rapidement qui
va faire le travail puis on peut
l'intégrer dans plein de trucs je vous
ai mis des petits cakes ici ou des
craquelins c'est quand même une poudre
c'est une poudre qui est somme toute
assez lisse qui est presque soluble ça
coûte la noisette tu parles avec du
monde qui sont là pour faire le travail
les ingénieurs c'est des scientifiques
le fun passe en deuxième ou en troisième
mais ceci dit ça goûte bon ce truc là
oui on s'en va dans l'espace pour aller
à la découverte c'est pas ça l'élément
principal mais pour garder le moral pour
prendre plaisir pour qu'il y a pas de
décrocher je pense qu'il faut bien
manger il faut y penser
c'est vrai que pour l'instant il y a eu
pas mal plus de recherches sur les
fusées que sur la nourriture alors
est-ce qu'on a encore le temps et on a
encore du travail à faire je pense pas
que le système nourriture ça va être
leur priorité numéro 1
au vu du fait que en l'espace de 6 mois
de développement on a eu ce résultat je
reste quand même optimiste
oui on peut y arriver il n'y a aucun
doute dans mon esprit et on peut
commencer demain matin
avoir l'enthousiasme des chercheurs on
peut penser que la table est mise pour
une future gastronomie extraterrestre